as states begin to certify their votes
and courts begin to rule on
team trump's legal challenges rudy
giuliani and sydney powell hold their
big presser but did they actually
release the kraken i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
my savvy fans secure
their internet join them at
expressvpn.com we're gonna get to all
the news and plenty there is of it in
just
one moment first why would you spend a
lot of money on your cell phone bill why
there's no reason
instead why don't you just go get pure
talk usa i've been talking about it for
a while here
you have the same coverage as any of the
big mobile companies but instead of
paying a fortune you're now paying a lot
less money
why well because those big companies
they charge you for unlimited data that
you are not using
here is what you need unlimited talk
text and two gigs of data for just 20
bucks a month
if you go over on data usage they're not
going to charge you for it switching to
pure talk is the easiest
easiest decision you will make today you
can keep your phone and your number or
get great deals on the latest iphones
and android grab your mobile phone dial
pounds at 250 say
ben shapiro there is no reason for you
to be spending too much money on your
cell phone bill
when you do when you dial pound 250 and
say ben shapiro you say fifty percent
off your first month
now pound two five zero say keyword ben
shapiro
a lot of phone companies intentionally
try to confuse you when you ask them to
describe the billing plan they give you
like a bunch of jargon
that's not the case at pure talk usa
because they're not overcharging you go
check them out right now pure talk is
simply smarter wireless style pound 250
say ben shapiro to get started
when you do you save fifty percent off
that very first month save a bunch of
money
with pure talk usa dial pound two five
zero say keyword ben
shapiro okay so there was big presser
yesterday this is the big news of the
day
big pressure yesterday rudy giuliani
jenna ellis
sydney powell this is the team trump
legal team they describe themselves
as the elite defense squad or something
like that okay so they are alleging
massive voter fraud and massive voter
regularity we're going to go through
their claims in detail
we're going to tell you what has been
fact checked and what has not what is
true
and what is not what requires more
evidence and what is sufficient
but we have to set the ground rules here
first okay what
people say in a press conference is of
zero not just
a little zero consequence to the actual
outcome
of the elections what happens in court
is of outcome to the election that has
an impact on the outcome
of the elections so if i say there's not
enough evidence at a press conference
that doesn't mean that not enough
evidence will be provided in court i
don't know what's provided in court
conversely
if somebody makes an outlandish claim at
a press conference that is not in and of
itself evidence sufficient to overturn
the results of elections in which
millions of people have voted you're
going to have to provide
heavy evidence okay so here's my job
right my job
is the same as my job is every day and
that is to try and suss out the
difference between
speculation and evidence it's to try and
tell you the difference between claims
that have been verified and claims that
have not been verified
and it's to ask for more evidence and
this is true for any
large-scale claim when people on the
left talk about systemic racism and the
evils of the american system i always
say i need specific evidence and i need
a specific claim so that i can tell you
whether it is true or false
when people on the left point to a
specific instance of a white cop
shooting a black man and they say this
is evidence that america is systemically
racist
i've asked this question a thousand
times i'll say okay you have evidence
that that is a racist shooting do you
have evidence that it connects to a
broader theme
of racism in america what is your data
what is your specific evidence
right we go through all of that asking
for evidence does not mean that i'm not
concerned about racism it means that i
am concerned about racism
it means that before we label an entire
system racist or an entire system
corrupt or even an individual corrupt or
racist we need to make sure that we have
evidence for the claim the same thing
holds true
in the realm of voter fraud and voter
irregularity if i'm asking for evidence
of a claim sufficient to overturn an
election
that's because there are serious issues
at play and when you're talking about a
legal strategy that is largely designed
at getting millions of votes thrown out
or revoked done in certain particular
states
or electors selected by the state
legislatures you need to provide
outsized evidence of those claims
evidence should be the baseline standard
for rational people it should be
anybody who tries to sell you if they
try to sell you a product without
evidence you should doubt them if they
try to tell you
that they have a big claim to make about
the universe without any evidence you
should doubt them
if you are talking about something as
large scale as a claim
that that maybe tens of millions of
votes but certainly millions of votes
were shifted for example
or that across the land huge swaths
of votes were discarded improperly or
counted improperly well then you should
be asking for the evidence right
that seems like the baseline bottom line
to me so we're going to go through the
claims
there are affidavits for some it's not
there's no evidence it's it's that
we will see whether there is evidence
sufficient to support the large scale
claims
that are being made now again here is
the note the press conference that
happened with giuliani
and ellis and powell yesterday it has no
actual legal bearing
and the time frame here is short so
we're hearing a lot from
trump team trump and and the giuliani
ellis and
and powell legal team that this is just
the beginning
they're going to be laying all this out
in the coming days there's not a lot of
time here
okay the clock is running if you want to
see the election results
change from what they currently are
right if you want to see the election
results
change because you believe there's
serious voter fraud and voter
irregularity you need to bring the
evidence now you don't have time to wait
three weeks you don't have time to wait
three months and that is why
if we are going to look at what team
trump is actually doing instead of
seeing what they are doing in press
conferences we should actually be
looking at what they are doing in court
and here is where things start to get
kind of dicey for team trump because the
fact is that states are starting to
certify those votes which means
you best expedite this stuff if you're
going to release the kraken that can't
just be a lot of talk at a press
conference
it actually has to be a lot of evidence
that you bring forth in a forum
likely to change the outcome because no
matter what you think or what i think of
the election no matter what anybody
thinks of the election
it is going to be certified unless
something factually changes on the
ground
and a lot of evidence is brought in
order to change the legal outcome of
various elections
right that is just the fact so here is
where things stand
as of right now in terms of court
filings and recounts and everything else
in georgia
georgia has now completed its hand tally
of the presidential race
in georgia gabriel sterling released the
information the associated press on
thursday they did a hand recount of
nearly 5 million votes
the state has until today to certify the
results that have been certified
and submitted by the counties once the
results are certified the losing
campaign can then request
another recount if they if they want one
okay the fact is that
the election numbers have not changed uh
there are about a thousand votes that
shifted over the course of the recount
because a bunch of votes were found
about a thousand votes shifted in the
hand recount over into the
trump camp or at least we're added to
the trump camp which means that right
now the deficit for trump
is about 13 000 votes where it was about
14 000 votes that's not enough obviously
to overturn the results
of the election and the high likelihood
is that the state of georgia is going to
certify
those election results borrowing some
sort of last minute
parachuting in of massive evidence of
voter fraud meanwhile
it is important to note that in
pennsylvania the trump campaign withdrew
its michigan election
lawsuit andy mccarthy writing over at
national review he says the washington
times reports the trump campaign has now
dropped a federal lawsuit in michigan by
which it challenged over a million
mail-in ballots in the hope of
preventing the state government from
certifying the election result
he says it is clearly a face-saving
measure the suit had no chance of
success the rationale the campaign is
given for dropping the case
is inaccurate we talked about this a
little bit yesterday that we've had a
little bit of a
of a mix-up confusion maybe some
pressure brought to bear
in the wayne county board of canvassers
there were two republicans and two
democrats the republicans initially
voted
not to certify the election results from
wayne county then they shifted over and
voted with the democrats to certify the
results then they filed affidavits
suggesting that they were pressured
into certifying the results all of this
was because the poll books didn't line
up poll books are where you sign
in to vote and then the number of votes
didn't match the poll books now the
grand total
number of discrepancies there was not in
the thousands it was not in the hundreds
of thousands apparently
including all of the discrepancies in
the poll books you were talking about
hundreds of votes
okay and they were talking about the
possibility of filing a lawsuit on that
basis
to overturn 1.4 million votes in wayne
county that obviously is not going to be
the proper remedy
you can't disenfranchise 1.4 million
people because the poll books didn't
line up for 350 votes the
discrepancy there is just too large and
you're talking about a state in which
trump right now trails on the count by
about 150
000 votes according to andy mccarthy the
campaign claimed the lawsuit was being
withdrawn as a direct result of
achieving the relief they sought with
wayne county
not certifying the vote but of course
wayne county did certify the vote so
that obviously is not even true
okay so trim trump withdrawing the the
lawsuit in michigan
that was a face-saving measure as andy
mccarthy says it was not because
they actually got what they wanted in
michigan they didn't get what they
wanted in michigan
so the the vote to certify the wayne
county ballot still under state law
is is going forward jim garrity
explained that for the
michigan county certifications to be
transmitted to the state cannabis award
that is the next step for full
certification
the trump campaign used the reported
recisions as an opportunity to to
declare an optical victory
and then drop the michigan lawsuit now
they're not
they're not claiming that there weren't
voter regularities they're just sort of
recognizing that they weren't going to
get the relief that they saw from the
courts and so they
they quietly dropped the lawsuits and
then claimed victory which of course is
not going to be effective
in actually changing the outcome of
everything happening in michigan
now meanwhile in pennsylvania something
similar has been happening
so as andy mccarthy says the the lawsuit
that was filed by team trump in
pennsylvania
was dependent on large-scale claims that
voter fraud had basically taken place
and then in the middle of the court
hearing
they actually dropped the charge of
voter fraud from the lawsuit itself
now that doesn't mean they didn't say
there was voter fraud they still say
there's voter fraud they just say that
their claim of voter fraud is not enough
to sustain the relief they are seeking
namely
to put aside the results of the election
as currently constituted
in pennsylvania they realize they
couldn't meet the high burden of proof
that voter fraud would require
and so they dropped that claim from
their pennsylvania lawsuit so if they're
out there claiming voter fraud
not in court and they're doing it
publicly that does not actually change
the outcome of the election it may
change public opinion on voter fraud
it's not going to change the outcome of
the election
in pennsylvania which means the window
continues to narrow we're going to get
to
more of this in just one second first
let's talk about
the fact that there's a significant
problem out there if you are a
law-abiding citizen and god forbid you
have to use your gun you could end up in
jail you could and this is why you need
legal services you need to know when you
can use your gun and how to use your gun
this is where the uscca comes in the
legal system is not always fair
responsibly armed americans often become
political targets and it's not right for
good responsible americans to wind up in
jail or embroiled in a lawsuit for
defending yourself or your family
in this day and age you need a gun to
protect yourself and you need to know
how to use it you need to have the legal
defense resources available
this is where the uscca comes in the us
concealed carry association
right now you can get a copy of the
complete concealed carry and family
defense guide from the uscca 100 free
in that guide you will learn how to
detect attackers before they see you
how to survive a mass shooting the
safest and most dangerous places to sit
in a restaurant how to responsibly own
and store gun even if you have little
kids and
especially if you have little kids a
whole lot more it's 164 page guide
loaded with valuable information just
text my name ben
to 87 222. you get instant access and a
chance to win a thousand bucks so you
can buy a gun to protect your family
again text ben to 87
222 to get started text my name ben to
87 222 you get instant access to that
complete concealed carry and family
defense guide and a chance to win a
thousand bucks
so you can buy a gun to protect your
family it's a pretty fantastic deal okay
so
again all this is giving the legal
background for where we currently stand
because whatever is said in a press
conference
is of no impact in a court what it said
in court is of impact in accord court
so according to andy mccarthy the
lawsuit in pennsylvania cannot
conceivably change the result in
pennsylvania
the court will probably not even rule on
the lawsuit the campaign
has sort of gotten a bad raps as andy
mccarthy for dropping its main counts
which allege that there were gross
improprieties amounting to fraud
in pennsylvania's tabulation of the vote
abandoning the accounts seemed
inexplicable on sunday given the
campaign was simultaneously alleging
massive fraud on tv but there is an
explanation
on friday the u.s court of appeals for
the third circuit issued a ruling that
destroyed the viability of those counts
the campaign shed the fraud related
accounts in response to the third
circuit court of appeals ruling the
fault lies in pressing ahead with a
narrower suit that can't change the
outcome of the race in pennsylvania even
in the unlikely event the campaign
prevails
so here is the here's the problem the
claims that are still alive in
pennsylvania are talking about again
hundreds or maybe low thousands of votes
they're not talking about the number of
votes
significant enough to actually call for
an overturning
of the election and basically team trump
acknowledges that
at this point the third circuit brings
us news of how negligible is the number
of votes involved when you're talking
about for example the claim by team
trump that a bunch of people had been
post
marking their their ballots after the
actual election date
apparently this is a very low number of
ballots
out of seven million total ballots cast
in the commonwealth of pennsylvania the
secretary of state reported to the court
only 9 383 votes were received statewide
in the three days after november 3rd
even if all of those were biden votes
which they weren't and if the court
avoided all of them which it won't
because some of them were in fact
postmarked before
november 3rd trump would still be 73 000
votes short in pennsylvania
only 655 total lack a legible postmark
which of course is not going to shift
the outcome of the election
also there's a problem between sort of
state and federal law the third circuit
explains there is no judicially
cognitible federal right to force state
or federal governments to comply
with the law okay normally you have to
claim that there's a federal right that
has been violated
if in fact the state law allows for
something to happen
it's hard to make an equal protection
claim on the federal basis
they said that there is no equal
protection violation because of the
state's three-day extension the court
noted that in addition to pennsylvania
19 states and dc permit the receipt of
votes post-election
voters don't suffer a cognizable harm
based on what for them is a formalistic
difference between whether post-election
receipt is authorized by statute
or by a ruling of the state's highest
court so they're saying it's not an
equal protection case
either okay so that doesn't mean that's
a good ruling it does mean that the
trump legal team's chances in
pennsylvania are
basically down to nothing unless they
actually come out
with serious robust evidence
of serious large-scale voter fraud okay
that is just the reality of the
situation
that's not me that's the law okay i
understand that people can be angry at
the law they can feel like the law
should allow for the overturning of
large-scale
voting based on the possibility of fraud
or based on
proof of small scale voter problems
that theoretically could be larger scale
voter problems but you don't have
evidence to prove it's hundreds of
thousands of votes
okay but the reality remains that that
is not how this is going to work
okay in the end if you make outsized
claims like we need to disenfranchise
seven million voters in pennsylvania or
we need to disenfranchise five million
voters in michigan
or we need to disenfranchise five
million voters in georgia
you're going to need more than a few
hundred votes were shifted here or
there's a possibility that hundreds of
thousands of votes were shifted but we
don't actually have proof
that these votes were shifted right
claimed outside
large claims require large levels of
proof
okay so if you're gonna release the
kraken now is when you need the tsunami
of evidence that demonstrates that
hundreds of thousands of votes were
shifted
right across the country and at the very
least that some 13 000 votes were
shifted in georgia if trump is supposed
to win georgia and 13 000 votes were
shifted in arizona or
went missing or were fraudulently
counted in arizona or that
150 000 votes were fraudulently counted
or shifted in michigan
or that 80 000 votes were shifted or
fraudulently counted
in pennsylvania right that is what
you're going to need to prove in court
so that is the predicate
right it would have to be a kraken right
you would need to actually have an
extraordinary
level of evidence now i'm not saying
that team trump doesn't have that
extraordinary level of evidence
i'm just saying that they need to
present it they don't need to present it
to me they need to present it to a court
but you can't keep coming out publicly
and saying you have presented the
evidence when you have not yet presented
the evidence publicly
and then say okay well it's in court and
the courts will see all of that evidence
okay well now you're where i am which is
okay the court's going to rule and the
process is going to move forward
now sort of the preemptive panic attack
that is happening in the media that the
election is going to be stolen
or that this is really horrible for our
democracy there's a legal process as
i've been saying since the beginning the
legal process will move forward the
legal process will require evidence
there will be if the legal process
does not find massive evidence of voter
fraud or voter irregularity and does not
overturn
the current vote counts there will be an
inauguration and there will be a
peaceful transfer of power mitch
mcconnell has said this every state
legislature has said this
okay and i will say that i don't think
that it's a great look that president
trump
has for example called up people in the
michigan legislature and ask them to
come visit the white house
in the middle of all of this right the
implication theoretically people are
speculating
is that trump is calling them up because
he wants them to come visit and then
he's going to convince them to elect a
slate of electors
as opposed to simply going along with
certifying the vote now michigan
legislature has already said we're not
going to do that we're not going to
ignore the votes of our millions of
people and just you know put up a slate
of electors based on vague allegations
of voter fraud or even specific but very
closely enumerated
allegations of voter fraud that don't
amount to the difference between joe
biden's vote
and your vote still it's not a
particularly good look
so once again here's all i'm saying
here's the predicate what happens in
court matters what happens an oppressor
doesn't
even an oppressor if you're going to
make a robust claim to the american
public
of serious voter fraud and serious voter
irregularity that requires
robust evidence not just of occasional
voter fraud or occasional voter
irregularity or even the possibility of
voter fraud or voter irregularity
i mean there are lots of possibilities
out there and i will take under
advisement all of those possibilities
i think there's plenty of ways that we
can clean up the system i think mail-in
voting is a full-scale mail-in voting
has been proved this time around
as always to be a disaster it is much
harder to check i've been in favor of
voter id in person on the day of voting
except for people who literally require
an absentee ballot because for health
reasons
or any other legit reason they cannot
get to the polling place
it turns out millions of people could
vote and it didn't spread covet
everywhere so
this was a bad idea it was a bad idea
beginning to end that does not mean
that the burden of proof has been
reached there is indeed a burden of
proof and allegations alone
and even affidavits alone attesting to
specific acts do not imply
that hundreds of thousands of votes were
shifted now sydney powell is claiming
something different sydney powell is
claiming that the system actually was
hacked and millions of votes were
shifted
we'll get to all of these allegations in
just one second because the press
conference
on the one hand is being taken by some
as this is the kraken the press
conference is alone
is enough for us to overturn the
election which is which is not correct
and then on the other hand you have
people saying everything in the press
conference is bull crap and we should
just ignore all of it and we should not
investigate any of these claims and that
of course
is silly as well all claims of voter
fraud and voter irregularity that are
legit
should be investigated that are credible
should be investigated also a burden of
proof
has to be reached okay that's just the
way it's gonna the election outcome
ain't gonna change
based on your opinion or my opinion it's
gonna change based on what is proved in
court
end of story and okay so we're gonna get
to the presser in just one second
and we'll see whether the whether the
kraken was indeed released first
let's talk about protecting your online
safety and security
okay so the fact is that a lot of the
silicon valley companies that hate your
gut
that don't want you to see information
that are currently downgrading
everything they don't like i'll talk
even about voter fraud and voter
irregularity
those same people suppressing your
ability to see information are actually
making money off of you
because you gave them permission
essentially by using their site to use
your data well why don't you revoke that
permission
and instead use express vpn big tech
companies can use your ip address to
match your internet activity to your
identity or location
when i use expressvpn search engines and
media sites can't see
my ip address at all my identity is
masked and anonymized expressvpn has the
added benefit of encrypting 100 of your
data to keep you safe from people you
don't want having it expressvpn software
takes just a minute to set up on your
computer or phone you tap one button
you're now protected
so if you're like me and you believe
your internet data belongs to you
and not to tech giants who are not
friendly to conservatives expressvpn
is the answer you have been seeking
protect your online activity today with
the vpn i trust to keep my data safe
visit expressvpn.com to claim an
exclusive offer
for my fans that is expressvpn.com for
three months free with one year package
visit expressvpn.com
ben to get started okay so finally we
got to the kraken releasing press
conference right we had been promised
this
sydney powell had said she was going to
release the kraken vast amounts of
evidence
that she was going to really demonstrate
full scale this election was stolen
and so the press conference leads off
with rudy giuliani
and rudy sort of lays out the
preliminary case he says that
you know it's very weird that on
election night trump was leading
by all of these votes and then by the
end of the election he was not leading
in a variety of these states
now you can call that weird the reality
is that that was
rather expected because the democrats
were really really pushing i mean you
remember this they were pushing
super hard mail-in voting right mail in
voting was their thing
trump was saying melon voting is bad
which is correct but that did dissuade a
lot of republicans from voting mail-in
instead they heavily outweighed
democrats on day of voting this was
expected right and then when the mail-in
votes started to be tabulated
at the end of the night because they're
tabulated after the in-person votes the
in-person votes are tabulated basically
on the spot
the election happens within an hour you
know what has been tabulated in person
and in places like pennsylvania they
were actually not legally allowed to
tabulate the mail-in votes
as those came in you started to see this
growing wave
for for biden in places like
pennsylvania but rudy says that the
timing was weird a lot of people did
find it weird here is rudy
the president way ahead on election
night seven or eight hundred thousand
in pennsylvania somehow he lost
pennsylvania
we have statisticians willing to testify
that that's almost statistically
impossible to have happened in the
period of time that it happened
but of course that's just speculation
okay that is just speculation so
then he gets to the actual specifics
okay so he says
in pennsylvania we have affidavits that
suggest
that there was mail-in voter fraud
here's the allegation
again remember important thing giuliani
represented team trump in court in
pennsylvania he was specifically asked
if they were making allegations of voter
fraud he said we are not
actually going to demonstrate legal
allegations of voter fraud because that
is a high bar for us to clear
that doesn't mean that voter fraud could
not have occurred right but it means
that this is not a claim he's actually
making in court here's rudy giuliani so
let's start with the specifics
pennsylvania in pennsylvania
the margin of victory now for biden
which is a not a victory it's a fraud
it's 69 140 votes
the reality is that we are now
at a count of 682 770 ballots
for which we have affidavits that there
was no inspection
of that ballot at the time that it was
entered
in the vote it was a mail ballot mail
ballots are particularly prone to fraud
so he
is not actually making an allegation
that fraud happened he is saying that
there weren't
observers who are close enough to the
ballot to be able to see the mail-in
ballots when they were tabulated and so
theoretically all of those could be
fraud
okay that that is a a pretty if you want
to get 700 000 votes thrown out you're
gonna have to show there was some fraud
in in those 700 000 votes that's a lot
of people remember each one of those
people is a person voting so
you have to assume a lot in order to in
order to get there
and again is there a possibility of
fraud yeah that's why you have election
observers but is that enough to throw
out 700 000 votes
you're gonna have to prove that in court
and again he didn't claim voter fraud in
court
it's important to recognize that what
you claim in court is what's actually
gonna be ruled upon now it gets claimed
in press conferences okay then giuliani
suggested
that the recount being done in georgia
is illegitimate the reason it's
illegitimate is because he says
that the signature that there was the
signature verification that happened
in georgia was inaccurate there was
signature matching
and signature matching was was done
poorly in georgia
because if you have an absentee ballot
then you put in an envelope you sign the
envelope the envelope signature is then
matched up
to the signature book right when you for
your
absentee ballot application they're
matched up then you throw away the
envelope and then you count the ballot
his suggestion is that there are a bunch
of people in georgia who basically were
not
matching up the the ballot envelope with
the actual
signature in the book so they were
counting naked ballots and those naked
ballots could have been fraudulent
here's giuliani trying to make that
claim
so for example the recount being done in
georgia will tell us nothing
because these fraudulent ballots will
just be counted again
because they wouldn't supply the
signatures to match the ballot
yeah we'll get to the sort of fact check
on that in just a second how the process
actually works
in georgia first let us talk about an
amazing gift that you can get for
somebody
this holiday season i mean it really is
an amazing gift that is quick it is easy
and it looks fantastic i'm talking about
my photo it's a game changer in a bunch
of photos
on your phone you're not doing anything
with them right you thought you were
going to like compile them into a book
too
too time-consuming you're just not going
to do it what you need to be able to do
is take that photo immediately send it
to my photo and then
within like five days you get back this
stunning gift box and in that gift box
is the picture on a metal glass or wood
creation
it's beautiful we have one we have
several actually in our home from my
photo that beautiful photo of me and my
wife
on the beach i literally just took my
phone i sent it into my photo and then
five days later arrived this acrylic
beautiful photo it's beautiful and
it shines like the light comes through
it's really really pretty i have one of
me and my wife and my kids
myphoto.com they make it quick they make
it easy you should go try it right now
go to myphoto.com you can easily see
your photo on all their products and
then simply purchase
you can use the promo code ben25 today
for 25
off go to myphoto.com right now use the
code bend25 get 25
off you'll see how easy and fun it is it
can actually be addicting it is very
easy it is very fast anybody can do it
it's not gonna take a lot of your time
and
it looks beautiful looks like you put a
lot of thought into something that
actually is gonna
really beautify your life go check them
out right now at myphoto.com i know the
founders of the company they're super
honest they're wonderful people
go check out myphoto.com use promo code
bend25 today
for 25 off okay so when giuliani
suggests that the the re recount in
georgia is ineffective because you are
actually just tabulating ballots
that the envelope was thrown away on the
outside right it was disconnected
uh and therefore it was never it was
never actually signature verified
he's correct you can't re-signature
verify the ballots right i mean that
part is true
once you've thrown away the part that
was the signature verification then
theoretically if you did it wrong the
first time you are re-tabulating a bunch
of ballots
that were originally mischecked but
brennan keith the chief investigator at
atlantis at wxia
he says signatures are verified before
ballots are counted they can't be
checked again in a recount under ga
under the georgia constitution because
that would betray the secrecy of a
voter's identity you would then know how
the voter voted and you'd be checking
their id at the same time
he says these these votes actually were
verified in 159 georgia counties
overseen by the republican georgia
secretary of state
any disputes or questionable signatures
went to a three-person adjudication team
one republican one democrat
one staffer okay so apparently
they were checked giuliani's claiming
that they weren't properly checked
he's gonna have to provide the evidence
of that allegation obviously in a
georgia court okay the next allegation
is he moved down to pennsylvania
and he says that in pennsylvania this is
a claim that is still part of that
pennsylvania lawsuit
and the idea is that in certain areas
you're allowed to cure your ballot more
easily than if you cured your ballot in
other areas
so you came in you cast a ballot
you realize you made a mistake on the
ballot you went over and now you were
allowed to cure your ballot or you sent
in an absentee ballot
and then you came in to check it and you
realized you'd screwed it up and you're
allowed to cure the ballot and he says
well the ballot curing period
for different areas was different and so
that's an equal protection violation
meaning that you have two different
standards
in two different counties number one the
number of votes in pennsylvania that
this happened to
is probably not the 70 or 80 not
probably not
almost certainly not the 80 000 vote
discrepancy that you're talking about
in pennsylvania and beyond that
the allegation presumably is that curing
the it's one thing to say curing the
ballots a week out is bad because it
violates statute it's another to say
that the curing the ballot standard at
the actual polling place
uh was was a little looser in one place
and a little less loose in another place
and this disenfranchised people you need
evidence that people who are republican
were disenfranchised
and the people who were improperly
voting were enfranchised
that evidence has not yet been provided
presumably that will be provided in
court raymond that's going to have to be
part of the court case here's giuliani
for example if you've made a mistake
in that ballot and you lived in
philadelphia or in pittsburgh
uh you were allowed to fix the mistake
but if you lived in the what would be
considered more
republican or trump par parts of the
state
you were given no such uh right
okay so again that is a claim that is
being made in pennsylvania court and
that will be adjudicated
he continues and he talks about
provisional ballots and here again
he's now alleging voter fraud but he is
not actually alleged voter fraud in
court i keep pointing out this
this discrepancy between what he alleges
in court and what he alleges an
oppressor
because what you allege an oppressor is
of no legal consequence what you allege
in court is what is of legal consequence
if you actually care about the outcome
of the election if you care about the
the sort of pr of this if you care about
you know the image that trump didn't
lose then the pressure matters but if
you actually are one of the people who's
invested in the outcome of the election
and in voter regularity and non-voter
fraud
then what happens in court is
significantly more impactful what
happens in court matters significantly
more so here's giuliani
suggesting that people went in and
fraudulently cast
provisional ballots now that is not an
allegation that he's made in court in
pennsylvania again that is important
it's important to note this stuff i
don't mean to be a wet blanket i don't
think it's being a wet blanket to say
that
i would love to see i would love nothing
better than to see donald trump
inaugurated again on january 20th in
order for that to happen
this stuff has to happen in court it
can't just be giuliani throwing things
out in a press conference that he then
does not allege in court here's giuliani
why did it happen 15 000 times that
people in pittsburgh walked in
to vote and they had already voted
according to the democrat
election machine
did they forget that many people
with uh bad memories in pittsburgh
or is the following correct that
uh as witnesses will testify they were
instructed by the
democrat bosses when they had a ballot
in which there was no one registered
just assign it to somebody
just assign it to rudy giuliani okay so
now the idea is that you have random
people basically
told by the democratic bosses walking
into pennsylvania
polling places and just taking out
fraudulently ballots that have not been
assigned to anybody yet right there was
an absentee ballot sent out nobody
turned it back in so you walked in
and you basically said you were that
person then you voted that's an
allegation of voter fraud again he's not
making that allegation in court
he says he has affidavits to prove it
okay seriously good
let's let's investigate all of those
affidavits let's see all those
affidavits that'd be that'd be good and
i'm not saying i need to see them but
the court certainly
is going to need to see them okay then
giuliani makes the case that
the observers republican observers were
not allowed in the room
in order to see what was going on now
what the courts have found is that
republican observers in places like
pennsylvania were allowed in the room
but that they were being put too far
away in certain cases since there was
this temporary injunction that was put
in place to get the observers a little
bit closer
uh here is giuliani talking about this
and then invoking my cousin vinnie this
of course the media only wanted to focus
on a couple things from this press
conference because they didn't actually
want to cover
a lot of the substance of the press
conference they focused in on two
particular things one
giuliani doing an entire scene from my
cousin vinnie which she actually did
uh and two the fact that giuliani who
dyes his hair had his hair dye who's
sweating a lot but his hair dye started
running
down his face in the middle of the press
conference which of course
is an optical booboo but has no impact
on the uh on what the man is actually
saying
here was here was giuliani
they weren't just not allowed to do it
they were
pushed a few cases they were assaulted
in all cases they were put in a corral
so far away probably the closest they
got
is from here to the back of that room
we could do like a did you all watch my
cousin vinnie
did you know the movie okay and then you
did a whole scene from my cousin vinnie
about the two fingers versus the three
fingers and they couldn't see exactly
what was going on again that is a voter
irregularity and that is bad and there
should be lawsuits on that basis are you
going to get the entire state of
pennsylvania
their vote toss probably not right i
mean the remedy just there
is not is not there legally okay we'll
get to michigan
in one second because there he makes the
most shocking allegation which is
literally that
giant busloads of ballots shipped in for
joe biden were sort of dumped
into the into the vast balloting okay
we'll get to that in just
one second plus we'll get to sydney
powell who made some some very
uh significant allegations about
dominion voting systems and suggests
that that
literally millions of votes were shifted
from one side to the other will go
through that
evidence there would be necessary okay
we're going to get to that in just one
second first
let us talk about the fact that you know
if you're a business owner very often
you've been operating through email
you've been operating through phone
calls
now the reality is that if a business
sends you an email you probably trash it
if
a business calls you out of the blue you
probably let it go to voicemail
people do tend to answer text messages
right text messages
tend to be an excellent way of ensuring
that people text you back because it
takes literally one second to open the
text
and then to respond to the text texts
get open 97 of the time so customers
will get your message you can text back
and forth it gives you the freedom from
being tethered to your phone this is
where podium comes in podium
is a service that allows you to
integrate
texting into your business model podium
works even better now the business is
being done remotely
car dealers are selling cars only
through text furniture stores are
sending order updates to keep their
customers
informed and now i'm teaming up with
podium for a special offer for a limited
time
sign up with podium for 20 off your plan
again they help convert
a lot of your business to text they are
so confident that if podium does not
make your business better within 90 days
they'll send you a 150
amazon gift card for the holidays go to
podium.com to get started there's a
great way to make your business more
efficient that's 20
off if you go to p-o-d-i-u-m podium dot
com
shapiro go to podium.com shapiro today
go check them out and make your business
more efficient podium.com
shapiro to get started that's 20 percent
off podium.com to get started
today okay we're going to get to more of
this press conference we haven't even
gotten to sydney powell
and her crack and release in just one
second we'll get to that first it is
that glorious time of the week when i
give a shout out to a daily wire member
today it is kim on twitter
who understands the value of unwavering
at consistency in this picture
the world's greatest beverage vessel
rests outside in front of an american
flag under a beautiful blue sky the
caption reads
during these ambiguous days the left is
still angry they're upset even though
they're man won
they want to throw temper tantrums and
yell at anyone who disagrees with them
while things may seem uncertain one
truth remains
this leftister's tumblr will stand the
test of time
truer words were never spoken thank you
for the picture and thank you for being
a daily wire member also
quick note you should become a daily
wire member why because we have to
replace
the legacy media the legacy media are
awful the legacy media worth 10 points
in this election to joe biden and kamal
harris they continue
to trot out narrative lies about the
wonders of joe biden
and they continue to trot out lies about
president trump and his covet handling
they refuse to give credit where credit
is due on operation warp speed but they
continue to claim that joe biden
shouting about mass is gonna fix
everything
they're just a joke they're their joke
okay and you need to replace them
and we would we would like to compete to
be their replacement and that means
that you need to subscribe with us to
join the crew we have big plans for the
next four years it starts today candace
owens is joining the daily wire she'll
be launching a brand new show with us
early next year
we're also going to be launching an
entertainment channel a new
investigative journalism team building
partnerships with like-minded content
creators like prageru whose entire show
library will be available to
dailywire.com members by the end of the
year we're going after the legacy media
we need your help to do it right now
just to show you we're serious we're
offering 25
off all memberships with code election
over at dailywire.com
subscribe today is indeed the last day
you can get this deal so sign up while
you can
members get our articles had free access
to all of our live broadcasts and show
library
the full three hours of the ben shapiro
show exclusive readers past content
available
only to daily wire members if you're
considering an all-access membership
you get to join us on all access live
every night for live stream discussions
with our hosts and an amazing online
community we also get not one but two
leftist tiers tumblers with your
membership
as well as early sometimes exclusive
access to new daily wire products so
remember
that is 25 off all memberships with code
election over at dailywire.com
subscribe replace the legacy media with
daily wire you will not
regret it also also you're going to want
to check out this week's
sunday special with abigail schreier
abigail is of course the author of a
book
about rapid onset gender dysphoria and
the move by the left to censor anybody
who talks about pressure from the
medical community and from the political
community
to allow children to transition before
they even know what the hell they are
doing
abigail has really weathered some slings
in here as to talk truth about
transgenderism and gender dysphoria you
can watch the show tomorrow a day early
by becoming a member
over at dailywire.com you're listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
okay so rudy then continues the
allegations
and uh and he talks about i i think the
most shocking allegation
uh he he alleges that there are four
people who gave affidavits
uh four who say that at 4 30 in the
morning a truck pulled up to a detroit
center where they were accounting and
just started unloading boxes
of ballots marked for joe biden now that
one seems like
that should be fairly easy for the media
to check in on right i mean they can
read those affidavits presumably if
those have been filed with a court
if you're taught now that that's that's
like a real allegation of voter fraud
right
and there's only one problem you
actually have to file that in a michigan
court
i am not clear on whether the trump team
has actually filed that michigan court
cause that's like
that's a serious real allegation you are
talking now about like jfk
dead people voting in chicago style
stuff from 1960. here's giuliani
alleging that
four affiants here those are people who
give affidavits
report an incident that under any other
circumstances would have been on the
front page of all your newspapers
if it didn't involve the hatred that you
have irrational pathological hatred that
you have
for the president what they
swear to is that at 4 30 in the morning
a truck pulled up to the detroit center
where they were
counting ballots and here's what they
jointly swear to that every ballot that
they could see
every thing they could hear these were
ballots for biden
i didn't see that i don't know that but
for the fact that
three american citizens are willing to
swear to it okay well we need the names
of the citizens we can talk to them we
need to know who exactly was counting
ballots at these places right i mean
this this is stuff that the media should
be able to check into
and certainly stuff that should be able
to be investigated i mean these are
actual criminal charges but he's now
alleging
wide scale voter fraud so good that's a
real allegation presumably with real
names on that so that is something
that can be checked right that at least
is a real allegation with with
and affidavits are in fact evidence
right affidavits are somebody testifying
that they saw a thing it is not just an
allegation at that point you are
swearing under penalty of perjury that
you saw a thing it doesn't mean that all
affidavits are true
it does mean that those are allegations
that ought to be investigated
so good okay there's only one problem
which is i am not sure that all of those
affidavits have actually been filed in
an ongoing case in michigan because
the other day the trump team as i
mentioned pulled out of their case in
michigan trump versus benson
and giuliani said they dismissed it
because the case was attempting to get
the wayne county board of supervisors to
decertified and they did
but they didn't right i mean that's the
problem is that they actually voted to
certify then they came back out and they
said
well we challenge our own certification
but there's no provision in michigan law
to do that
so herein lies the problem again there's
a difference between what giuliani's
alleging on the public stage
and what is actually being filed in
court if you want the election changed
it has to be filed in court it doesn't
matter what he says in front of a
microphone it doesn't settle
it doesn't matter what giuliani says in
front of cameras it doesn't matter what
he says in interviews it matters what
gets filed
in court it matters what gets filed in
court that is all
that is all okay so file it in court
again this is he's making serious
allegations and apparently he's got
affidavits to back it
this would be a great time for a lawsuit
in michigan suggesting
that all of this needs to be postponed
the certification needs to be postponed
until the investigation
is completed giuliani concluded by
saying
that uh somebody had a plan to shift the
election
all right and uh and he he sort of
concluded with his with his big
wrap up this would be giuliani clip 12.
isn't the logical conclusion that i
think any jury would accept
as they heard this evidence that
somebody had this plan
maybe that was always the plan that's
the reason why hillary clinton said
don't concede even if you're losing
that's the reason we had a freudian slip
by the candidate
and he said he had the best voter fraud
team in the country
that's the reason why he probably didn't
have to go out and campaign
he had to have known what they were
going to do okay
so then sydney powell comes up and cindy
powell of course was the lawyer in the
michael flynn case
she's been well respected uh she she
gets up and she starts talking about the
kraken right this is the release the
kraken moment she's the one who
originally
started using that phrase that she was
going to reveal evidence that literally
millions of votes were shifted in the
election this is the biggest allegation
now giuliani is talking about specific
voter fraud and voter irregularity
allegations some of them have been
alleged in court others have not been
election court
some he says he has affidavits for
others he he has said he does not have
affidavits for
all of that is gonna get hashed out in
courts powell is the one who is making
the biggest claim here
so she claims that the voting system of
the united states was hacked
that is a massive claim not that there
was a possibility of hack but that there
was a hack
that in fact the voting systems of the
united states were compromised
which means that you can't trust any
election result i mean not just the
presidential election result
any place that used a dominion voting
system presumably would now be in
question and in fact she actually does
say that in this press conference so
here is sydney powell
laying forth her theory of what happened
here with dominion voting systems and
smartmatic technology
what we are really dealing with here and
uncovering
more by the day is the massive
influence of communist money through
venezuela
cuba and likely china in the
interference
with our elections here in the united
states
the dominion voting systems the
smartmatic
technology software and the software
that goes in other computerized voting
systems here as well
not just dominion were created in
billions
in venezuela at the direction of hugo
chavez
to make sure he never lost an election
after one constitutional referendum came
out the way he did not want it to come
out
okay so she is essentially saying that
smartmatic and dominion are the same
that smartmatic is a subsidiary
of dominion voting systems and that
smartmatic was developed
in venezuela software was developed in
venezuela at the direction of hugo
chavez who of course has been dead since
2013 but the idea is
that hugo chavez's venezuelan voting
system has been sort of
taken up into the american voting system
and is still significantly vulnerable
to hack she continues along these lines
suggesting that the software itself has
back doors that allow people to hack in
and then change votes from one party to
the these are these are the sorts of
allegations
that if true completely blow up voting
in the country i mean that's how large
these allegations are
if you are alleging that the dominion
voting system which is used in 24 states
that dominion voting system is so not
just that there's a possibility of
compromise but that it was so heavily
compromised
that millions of votes were shifted then
you were talking about
redoing the entire election essentially
i mean
it's the end and it's the end of this of
trust in elections period in the united
states
if what cindy pal is saying is true so
here she is explaining
what she thinks happened with the
software
now the software itself was created with
so many variables and so many
back doors that can be hooked up to the
internet or a thumb drive stuck in it or
whatever
but one of its most characteristic
features is is its ability to flip
votes it can set and run an algorithm
that probably ran all over the country
to take a certain percentage of votes
from president trump and flip them to
president biden
which we might never have uncovered had
the votes for president trump not been
so
overwhelming in so many of these states
that it broke
the algorithm that had been plugged into
the system
and that's what caused them to have to
shut down in the states they shut down
in that's when they came in the back
door with all the mail-in
mail-in ballots okay so what she's
alleging right now is that there's an
algorithm
that was used in the software from
dominion and that this algorithm
was was designed to create
from whole cloth votes for joe biden to
outweigh the votes
from donald trump and that trump's vote
was so heavy in a lot of the states
where he was doing well early in the
night like georgia and arizona wisconsin
michigan
pennsylvania that the shutdown was not
in fact a shutdown what the shutdown was
was the algorithm shut down the machines
and now all the people came in the back
door with all the fake ballots right
that lines up with what giuliani is
saying about these affidavits suggesting
that there are all of these printed out
fake ballots
for joe biden which is a pretty
sophisticated but
also not supremely hard to evidence
conspiracy right i mean if that if that
is true
you should be able to get a hold of one
of the dominion voting systems machines
and you should be able to check for the
algorithm you should be able to identify
the algorithm
also i'm not sure how an algorithm gets
broken like honestly i'm not a software
person so i don't know
if that is a plausible allegation or if
that is not a plausible
allegation pell suggests that that these
machines were essentially preset right
she says
that they were preset to change the
ratio of a biden vote to a trump vote
here she is continuing along these lines
there's an algorithm that runs that
automatically flips all the votes and
then each operator has the ability to go
in
override settings they can ignore
signature they can ignore the
the top line of the ballot they can go
down ballot and select whoever they want
to change the results for
mr mcgee the gentleman who founded
smartmatic there's video of him on the
internet
explaining that yes and at least one
occasion he admits
they changed a million votes with no
problem
okay so the the basic idea here
is that the algorithm was in the
computer it was already being gamed
trump's vote was overwhelming it broke
the algorithm and they brought in a
bunch of ballots
through the back door and that
smartmatic was once a venezuelan
technology and so it was designed
exactly for
this sort of thing and that is the
allegation that is an extraordinary
allegation
right that allegation would require
extraordinary evidence because you're
talking about the wrecking of the entire
american system by dominion
is what you're talking about right here
now
maybe it's true maybe it is seriously
but you'd actually have to provide some
evidence of that
they were asked in this presser do you
actually have you know like access to a
dominion voting system and they
basically said not really uh and then
they were asked you know do you have
evidence of how the algorithm worked and
they said well you know we have like
people talking about it
all that's fine if this allegation is
real
then investigate it down again trust in
the american system requires that
allegations be investigated
down to the root the allegation is not
sufficient overturn the election however
and it has to be done in court
right that's what you have a system for
and so you know
now is gonna be the time for the actual
kraken to be released so
jenna ellis came out right and she sort
of acknowledged that there had not been
a lot of evidence presented in this
press conference specifically she says
this is the opening argument
so what you've heard now isn't basically
an opening statement
this is what you can expect to see when
we get
to court to actually have a full trial
on the merits
to actually show this evidence in court
and prove
our case okay that's fine and i'm
hearing a lot of people today saying you
know you
and tucker carlson and other people you
keep saying that you want more evidence
and the evidence will be shown in court
okay that's fine with me show the
evidence in court by all means
right by all means show the like that's
what i'm saying show the evidence in
court
but i'm also getting a lot of people who
are saying well the fact that the
allegations are made that demonstrates
that this election was completely
illegitimate top to bottom
okay it's not going to be ruled that way
unless this thing actually goes to court
i'm repeating myself a lot here to be
extremely clear on
on a political level nothing would make
me happier than for donald trump to
retain the oval office
i voted for him i supported him in order
for that to happen
all these allegations are going to need
to be supported in court
and extraordinary allegations like the
venezuelans created a voting system that
was then ingested into dominion
used in 24 states and then people were
literally paying off people in order to
game the system
that's going to require some evidence
okay by the way that's what sydney
powell suggested sydney pal didn't just
suggest that joe biden had game the
system
she suggested that candidates all over
america had gained the system
right she actually she actually claimed
that republicans and democrats is
clipped 21
republicans and democrats paid dominion
this is how dominion apparently makes
its money
is by people taking bribes in dominion
in order for them to in order for them
to
be voted for via this this corrupt
algorithm
i might speak for just a minute in terms
of the level of corruption we are
looking at here
we have no idea how many republican or
democratic
candidates in any state across the
country
paid to have the system rigged to work
for them
these people didn't do this just to take
control they make
one heck of a lot of money off of it
okay so that is
the suggestion now is that dominion
doesn't make its money off of being paid
by states in order to use their voting
system
hundreds of millions of dollars they
make their money off of direct bribes
from particular i mean this is an
extraordinary allegation it's an
extraordinary allegation and it requires
extraordinary evidence
it does okay and it is important to note
that at this point
dominion was used in georgia the
allegations are being made about
dominion
the hand count in georgia matches the
dominion voter tabulation
in georgia so you're going to have to
explain how that happened giuliani's
theory
is that a bunch of absentee ballots were
fraudulently kind of put into the system
that matched up directly with the
dominion voting system
that essentia so it wasn't really the
algorithm that did it was the it was the
fraudulent ballots that did it okay
evidence in any case is going to need to
be presented here as far as dominion and
whether dominion actually has
these sorts of voter fraud backdoor
possibilities listen any system can be
hacked
but beyond that the question is whether
dominion actually is just an offshoot of
venezuelan technology
dominion is actually owned since 2018 by
staples street capital a new york
private equity firm according to the uk
independent
both dominion and smartmatic have
released statements saying no ownership
relationship exists between the two
competing firms in fact they are in
competition smartmatic makes voting
machines
so does dominion they both make their
own voting software smartmatic is an
international company incorporated in
florida by venezuelan founders
dominion does not have any direct ties
to venezuela they don't have any
systematic partnership with smartmatic
smartmatic technology was used in
venezuelan elections accusations by
government opponents that the company
rigged elections there were
unsubstantiated in 2017
the company itself smartmatic accused
venezuelans government of electoral
fraud
here's how this all works marmatic
purchased the voting machine company
sequoia voting systems in 2005 then sold
it two years later
after objections were raised over its
partnership with the company in which
venezuela's government had invested
and then three years after smartmatics
sold sequoia dominion acquired sequoia
so the accusation is that sequoia had a
bunch of venezuelan technology in
sequoia and then dominion acquired
sequoia and so all of the
smartmatic technology supposedly
corrupted by the venezuelans was taken
up into
sequoyah and then dominion acquired
sequoia
security experts say it's difficult to
know for certain whether some sequoia
code may be used in dominion's software
because of the industry's limited
transparency both dominion and
smartmatics say they do not use the same
software dominion put out a statement on
its website whether it's true or not
the hell knows dominion has no company
ownership relationships with any member
of the pelosi family the feinstein
family the clinton global initiative
smartmatic
cital or any ties to venezuela
smartmatic also says they've never owned
any shares or had any financial stake in
dominion voting systems smartmatic has
never provided dominion voting systems
with any software hardware
or other technology the two companies
are competitors in the marketplace okay
so that is what the companies claim
at the very least all of this should be
susceptible to investigation
and will have to be proved in court
obviously
so that is uh that is where things
currently stand
okay so was the kraken released well it
depends on what you mean by kraken if
the allegations
are extraordinary then yeah if what you
mean is a wave of evidence sufficient to
overturn election results that's only
going to be done in court it hasn't been
done yet
and it is not a sin for people to ask
for that evidence to be shown in the
court of public opinion before i make up
my mind
on the veracity of the claims themselves
when you make an extraordinary claim i
require extraordinary evidence
it's just what everybody should do okay
so that is where things currently stand
that is a bevy of allegations that have
been
put forward the dominion ones are
particularly stunning uh if they can be
substantiated in any way
then that will undermine not only public
confidence in our elections it will
undermine elections that have been held
using dominion systems for the last
several years it would be a disaster
area for the country but of course
more of a disaster area would be moving
forward with a fraudulent selection if
that could be proved but
evidence evidence evidence now tucker
carlson said the same thing last night
and we asked on cindy powell this week
cindy powell did not get back to us on
appearing on the show
tucker apparently also asked on sydney
powell this week
and he said powell needs to show us the
evidence and in fact when we asked her
for the evidence she got mad and then
cut off communications
but she never sent us any evidence
despite a lot of requests polite
requests
not a page when we kept pressing she got
angry and told us to stop contacting her
when we checked with others around the
trump campaign people in positions of
authority they told us
powell has never given them any evidence
either nor did she provide any today
at the press conference powell did say
that electronic voting is dangerous and
she's right we're with her there
but she never demonstrated that a single
actual vote was moved illegitimately by
software
from one candidate to another not one
okay and
this is correct right tucker's not wrong
to request evidence you're not wrong to
request evidence
everybody should be requesting evidence
at this point and this is what the polls
show
some 46 of americans say they think that
trump
should concede right away which means 54
of americans don't agree
and of those 54 of americans about 32
of americans came up with the correct
answer to this question
which is it depends on what the evidence
shows evidence
is the standard evidence should always
be the standard in every case
well for her pal for her part sydney
powell responded to tucker by saying i'm
not gonna present all the evidence
because we're gonna do that
in court and i'm not busy doing
interviews i mean she kind of is busy
doing interviews
obviously right she she uh she
came out yesterday and did an interview
i believe lou dobbs suggesting that the
election results in all the swing states
should be overturned
well if you're gonna do an interview
suggesting that then you kind of have to
provide the evidence to back that that's
a pretty extraordinary ask no i mean we
are talking about
millions of votes across the united
states which does matter regardless
of whether you're a democrat or
republican you should want all the votes
counted
well yes lou the entire
election frankly in all the swing states
should be overturned and the
legislatures
should make sure that the electors are
selected for trump
and it's going to have to follow the
constitutional provisions
that it go be decided according to the
amendment okay well unfortunately sydney
powell's team
uh when it came she'll do an interview
with with
with lou dobbs she wasn't going to do
one with tucker carlson and her team
apparently got very angry at tucker for
suggesting that evidence
be presented uh apparently uh the the
in-house counsel for sydney powell pc
molly mccann responded to carlson's
demand for transparency by saying that
he sounded like a spoiled brat
she said the million-dollar question
isn't why won't sydney who barely has
time to sleep or eat text tucker the
evidence he wants
the question is why won't tucker text
her and say whenever you are ready and
if you choose my platform is at your
disposal to present your case to the
nation
until then good luck in the fight okay
but he actually said that on a show he
literally said
i will offer you the full week to take
over my show and present the evidence
so that's not on tucker that's not on
tucker
okay so that is present the evidence
it's not crazy to say that joni ernst
the the senator from iowa
and she she was commenting on powell's
comment right pal paul's most
outrageous comment was that candidates
republican and democrat all over the
united states are paying dominion voting
systems in order to big elections which
is
an extraordinary claim again and joni
ernst was like that's kind of crazy i
mean
you shouldn't be claiming that
candidates are rigging elections all
over the place
willy-nilly i mean my goodness senator
i mean did you or any of your republican
colleagues in the senate pay to have
their elections rigged no
and that that is an offensive comment
for for those of us that do stand up
and represent our our states in a
dignified manner
we believe in honesty we believe in the
integrity
of our election system okay so
yeah again for the one millionth time
big allegations require big evidence end
of story
okay if that evidence is not provided
it's going to be very hard for anything
to be proved or for allegations that are
very large
to be taken seriously in 2004 democrats
claimed that the dibo voting machines
had been hacked they could not provide
any evidence of that
voting machines machines haven't been
hacked and so we rightly said we're not
going to pay any attention to that
now we're going to need evidence that
this happened because this is the
biggest voting scandal in the history of
the united states bar
none if what sydney powell is saying is
true and the same thing is true if rudy
giuliani's claims
are true and now yesterday this all
culminated in media members doing what
media members do so instead of saying
okay we'd like to see the evidence can
we see the evidence
instead of saying let's let the process
play out which is what i'm saying it's
what tucker's saying we're all saying
the same thing
everyone's saying this instead of that
your mainstream media members decided
it's time to yell at people right that's
really what's important so
mike pence was doing a presser on covet
at 19. which by the way some good news
fizer has now requested emergency
authorization to start distributing his
vaccine by the end of this month which
is actually real good news
right so pence does oppressor and the
media members lose their bleep
right as pence is walking off it just
shows you what journalism has basically
become
which is performative nonsense for the
cameras so
pence didn't take questions he's walking
off and media members just start
shouting at the top of their lungs at
him
and they know he's leaving right he's
not turning around he's not answering
the questions it's just if i
if i'm caught on camera shouting at him
then i get my scene in the movie to be
made about the evils of the trump
administration
backlit and uh and with an upshot to
show my heroism her media members just
yelling at mike pence randomly
about what's going on with the election
[Music]
so is that like a good thing honestly
there is another point to be made here
in all of this regardless of what the
allegations end up being or what what
evidence it ends up showing
there is a systemic distrust of the
system that is now set in
for for tens of millions of americans
tens of millions
of them who say that they don't trust
election outcomes this is true right and
left they don't know who to trust when
it comes to this stuff because it seems
like
nobody is telling them the truth and
that is because they believe that
everybody is badly motivated
and in a lot of cases they are right
when trump supporters look
at the journalistic entities who are
saying and just dismissing out of han
giuliani's claims or powell's claims
when they see that and these people are
not saying okay we need to see the
evidence they're just immediately
dismissing it
or when they say voter fraud has never
happened anywhere or when they say that
the polls are absolutely correct
or when they say it's clear that russian
collusion happened trump voters are
going to respond by saying we're not
going to listen to anything
that you have to say scorn does breed
retaliatory scorn and distrust
okay that is just the way that human
beings behave and there's a reason
for that so it does make a difference it
does make a difference when you have
columns like one from wajahat ali in the
new york times suggesting that reaching
out to trump supporters is a bad idea
he has an entire article in the new york
times yesterday in which he talks about
how he after 2016 decided he was going
to travel the country and talk to trump
supporters
but his entire articles about how he
went around he talked to trump
supporters and they didn't change their
minds and therefore they are bad
and terrible and horrible and racist he
says this in ohio i spent 90 minutes on
a drive to the airport with a retired
trump supporter we were cordial to each
other we made jokes we shared stories
about our families
neither of us changed our outlook
they'll never take my guns ever he told
me explaining his facebook feed was
filled with articles
about how hillary clinton and democrats
would kill the second amendment and
steal his guns
although he didn't like some of mr
trump's tones and comments he didn't
believe he was a racist in his heart
i'm not a cardiologist so i wasn't
qualified to challenge that
he says i did my part what was my reward
listening to mr trump's base chance send
her back
we cannot help people who refuse to help
themselves mr trump is an extension of
their id their culture their values
their greed
he is their defender and savior he is
their blunt instrument he is their
destructive drug of choice
the truest thing trump has ever said is
they don't hate him
they they don't hate you because they
hate him they hate him because they hate
you
and so people respond to the media
simply dismissing all claims out of hand
with regard to
to trump and the election they regard
that as just an extension of the media's
scorn for them
and honestly it's hard to blame people
for that it may not be correct
but it's certainly justifiable i mean
when you see the way that that
democrats on twitter react to trump
supporters
it's insane for example california
democratic regional director
tweeted out this no seriously how do you
deprogram 75 million people where do you
start fox
facebook we have to start thinking in
terms of post-world war ii germany or
japan
or the failures of reconstruction in the
south
okay that's crazy he says this is not
your standard partisan policy
disagreement
this is a conspiracy theory fueled
belligerent death cult against reality
and basic decency the only actual policy
debate of note
are happening within the democratic
coalition between the left and the
center left right this is what
democrats think of you he says i know
conservatives are upset by some of the
responses here and yeah many are out of
line but what do you expect people to do
in self-preservation the right has been
running
four years on bleep your feelings my
conspiracy theories are valid opinions
and we have more guns
well no the right has been acknowledging
that the left has cultural
scorn for them and that is going to
breed retaliatory scorn
it's going to breed a level of distrust
that is endemic to the system
and every time you tweet crap like this
you are you are creating more distrust
in the systems that are required right
when you declare that barack obama is
the arbiter of truth and then everybody
says okay well i don't trust you anymore
what do you think is going to happen
joyce carol oates who is a
a another writer famous writer and a far
lefty
who tweets out pictures of her weird
feet that is a thing she tweeted out the
other day
for many pro-trump americans and she she
bleeps out trump because it's a bad word
for many pro-trump americans the
pandemic is like the holocaust to many
germans
they knew what was happening but
adjusted to living with it in a
difference or in some cases profiting
from it
only if affected personally do people
seem to care and so if you are a trump
supporter
and you are disagreeing with joyce carol
oates on covet response
it's because you're like a german
ignoring the holocaust and then we're
expected to trust
these people we're expected to trust
that they have a good hearted search
for truth at heart i think not i think
not
that that is what is driving a lot of
this yeah i've been saying on a wide
variety of issues there should be
bipartisan agreement
on how we handle a lot of these issues
when it comes to voter fraud evidence
right evidence of voter fraud when it
comes to covet policy follow the
evidence don't make it up
don't follow political incentives follow
the evidence when it comes to racism in
america
follow the evidence it's all the same
standard but
when people pretend that they are
arbiters of truth and they only examine
evidence
in cases they want to examine evidence
and then they sneer at people who
disagree with them
the predictable result is that people
are going to react by disregarding
everything they have to say
and saying okay you don't you didn't
require evidence for stacey abrams you
didn't require evidence for four years
of russian collusion bull crappery
you didn't require five minutes of
explanation of evidence for that sort of
stuff and we were put through four years
of that
and now you expect me to to respect your
demands for evidence i think not
either there's going to be one standard
or there's going to be no standard there
is not going to be a double standard
for most americans either evidence is
required for claims or evidence is not
required for claims
so pick a side are you on the evidence
side or are you in the are you on the
not evidence side
right that that is the real quest and
that's true for everything it's true for
everything from covert policy
to election fraud to race policy
whatever it is require evidence for
claims that is the side of truth
is the side that cares about evidence
okay well before we break for the
weekend
it's time for a little bit of a bible
talk because let's have some uplift
going into the weekend so this week
the jews read a portion of the five
books of moses
called todo this is the this is the
portion of the bible that deals with the
selling of the birthright from from esau
to
jacob and also the blessing that isaac
gives to jacob instead of esau the
so-called stealing of the birthright and
sort of common biblical powers
and so for folks who don't know the
story basically isaac
who of course is abraham's son and he
now has kids and he has twins
asav esau and jacob right and esau is
sort of a man of the fields he's a wild
man
he's a hunter he's not a man of soul
jacob is a is a
man of soul who is described as dwelling
in tents
okay esau and jacob sort of battle for
primacy that's that's sort of the rest
of the book of genesis is them battling
for primacy in various ways
esau is the firstborn uh jacob grabs
onto his heel right that is why he's
called yaakov because the word
uh ekkev in hebrew means he'll he grabs
onto asav's heel he grabs onto esau's
heel
and so now they grow up as they get
older it becomes very clear that esau
spurns the birthright
he doesn't actually want the
responsibilities of being the firstborn
and so for
literally a bowl of lentil soup he sells
his birthright
to jacob what that really means is that
for any rationale whatsoever he was
willing to give away the responsibility
of being
the firstborn but isaac is not green
with this right their father has not
actually greenlit this switcharoo
and esau it turns out actually he kind
of spurns it but at the same time he
still wants the benefits of the
birthright without actually the
responsibilities of the birthright
so this brings us to the critical scene
in question one of the most
sort of puzzling parts of the bible
so this is genesis chapter 27. it came
to pass when isaac was old and his eyes
were too dim to see that he called esau
his elder son and he said to him my son
and he said to him here i am and he said
behold now i have grown old i do not
know the day of my death
so now sharpen your implements your
sword and your bow and go forth to the
field and hunt game for me
and make for me tasty foods as i like
and bring them to me and i will eat in
order that my soul will bless you before
i die
but rebecca who's isaac's wife overheard
when isaac spoke to esau his
son and esau went to the fieldton game
and to bring it and rebecca said to
jacob her son saying behold
i've heard your father speaking to esau
your brother saying bring me game and
make me tasty foods and i will eat and i
will bless you before the lord before my
death
and now my son harkens my boy to my
voice it's what i am commanding you
go now to the flock take from me for me
from there two choice kids
i will make them tasty foods for your
father as he likes and you shall bring
them to your father that he may eat in
order
that he bless you before his death and
jacob said to rebecca his mother behold
my brother esau is a hairy man whereas i
am a smooth man
perhaps my father will touch me and i
will appear to him as a deceiver and i
will bring upon myself a curse and not a
blessing
and his mother said to him on me is your
curse my son only harkens my voice
and go take them for me so he went and
he took and he brought them to his
mother
and his mother made tasty foods as his
father liked and rebecca took the costly
garments
of esau her elder son which were with
her in the house and she dressed jacob
her younger son
and the hides of the kids she put on his
hands and on the smoothness of his neck
right so she actually takes hair and
puts it on
on jacob so that he feels more like his
older brother he came to his father and
he said my father and he said here i am
who are you my son
and jacob said to his father i am esau
your firstborn i have done as you have
spoken to me
please rise sit down eat of my games
that your soul will bless me
and isaac said to my son how is it that
you have found it so quickly my son he
said because the lord your god prepared
it for me
and isaac said to jacob please come
closer so that i may feel you my son
whether you are really my son esau or
not so obviously isaac suspects
something at this point jacob draws near
to isaac his father he felt him he said
the voice is the voice of jacob
but the hands are the hands of esau
right
yaakov and in the hebrew and he didn't
recognize him because his hands were
hairy like the hands of his brother esau
and he blessed him and he says again are
you indeed my son esau and he said i
am and he said serve it to me i may eat
of the game of my son so my soul will
bless you he served him he ate he
brought him wine and he drank
and his father said come closer and kiss
me right he's constantly like something
isaac knows something is up right he's
losing his sight but he knows something
is up he came closer he kissed him he
smelled like the fragrance of his
garments he blessed him he said behold
the fragrance of my son is like the
fragrance of a field
which the lord has blessed okay and then
the story continues with jacob receiving
the blessing and
esau returns and when esau returns
he uh he explains to isaac what has
happened and isaac shutters
and he says who then is the one who
hunted game and brought it to me and i
ate of everything while you had not yet
come and i blessed him he too
shall be blessed when he saw heard his
father's words he cried out a great
embarrassed said was father blessed me
too oh my father he said your brother
came with cunning and took your blessing
and uh and so he doesn't reverse the
blessing so it's a really puzzling story
right
because why wouldn't he reverse the
blessing if i give you a gift
but i do so under the false premise that
you are another person
i can take that gift back as it turns
out right the bible makes it sound like
isaac is on his deathbed
isaac in the bible lives like another
two decades at no point does he reverse
his judgment
and actually remove the blessing from
jacob who lied to him and give it back
to esau who did not lie to him so what
exactly is going on here
so the answer i think lies in the
characters of esau and jacob and eliza
and what we should strive for as human
beings
so esau is described in the bible again
as a ruddy man which means man of
violence he's described
as a as a person who is uh who's very
capable in the fields right he can use a
sword and he can use a bow
but he's not a person who is described
as anything but sort of selfish
he he respects his parents somewhat but
that's pretty much his big quality
and so he's a man who's capable of
survival but he is not a moral man
jacob by contrast is a moral man but
he's sort of perceived
as soft right he's not a survivor he's
not somebody who can survive and so
isaac has a choice to make because he is
now going to hand on his birthright
which means the future
of the hebrews the future of the jewish
people and in his view of his his family
and his civilization
who's he going to hand that birthright
to to preserve the civilization the
survivor without morality
or the moral man without a survival
instinct right that's the real question
so what happens he tells esau
i want you you're the survivor i think
you can learn morality go out to the
field
do something for me instead of just
killing an animal and then eating it
yourself
or killing an animal for fun go do
something that demonstrates
honor for a parent and then i will bless
you because you'll have merited
the blessing because you're both a
person capable of survival and you're a
person who's capable of
higher moral thinking and rebecca his
wife hears this and she says well i
don't think that's right i mean i know
ace i know esau i know jacob i know esau
is not a moral man and i don't think
he's going to develop a moral instinct
but i do think that jacob is capable of
developing a survival instinct
and so jacob dons his brother's clothes
he puts on the the hair on his hands and
on his neck
and he goes and he meets with with isaac
and
isaac knows something is wrong right
that sentence where he says how cold
cole yaakov right the voice is the voice
of jacob
but the hands are the hands of esau
and he suspects that something is up
he's saying it doesn't matter which one
of my sons this is right this is
actually as it turns out
what is happening it doesn't matter
which one of my sons i'm blessing this
is the son who deserves the blessing
because either this is esau who has
grown a soul or this is jacob who's
grown a spine
this is either esau who's determined how
to become a moral person because he's
speaking in respectful ways to me and
he's doing what i wanted him to do
or this is jacob who has actually
become a survivor right is capable of
doing the things necessary for survival
in a cruel and unjust world right that
is the
the and so he decides that the future of
of
his family line is better placed in the
hands of the person
who actually did all the things that
that were needed to be done and that's
why he doesn't reverse the blessing
even though he realizes what has
happened at that point right he his eyes
are open
and he realizes what has happened
he he wanted it to be is his firstborn
but esau had already given away the
birthright once because he actually
didn't want the responsibility jacob
wanted the responsibility and jacob was
willing to do
what it took in order to gain that
responsibility including
an act of deception in order to
demonstrate to his father that he was in
fact capable of survival
and that's what it takes to live in the
world it does doesn't mean that you have
to act deceptively when you don't have
to
it does mean that you need to be able to
survive you need to be able to act
aggressively
you need to be able to act in defense of
your own family and of your own values
but you have to have the values too
and it is easier to grow an aggressive
streak from a moral center and it is to
grow a moral streak from an aggressive
center
that's the message of the of the selling
of the birthright
as well as the blessing that is given by
isaac to jacob rather than to esau it's
why jake it's why
isaac doesn't revoke his own blessing
alrighty we'll be back here next week
with much more we'll give you all the
updates if the kraken the evidentiary
kraken is released not just the
allegations kraken the evidentiary
kraken is released
we'll bring you all of it next week have
a wonderful weekend
stay safe out there this is the ben
shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are nick sheehan and
rebecca doyle
the show is edited by adam scievent
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by nika geneva the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 20 20. you know the
matte wall show
it's not just another show about about
politics i think there are enough of
those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about i
hope you'll
give it a listen